you may know her from paris but lily
collins is hollywood through and through
and it's like how many questions can you
ask about my dad because to me his dad
the tv star was destined for show
business starting with a rock star dad
and marrying into acting royalty let's
take a look at lily's star-studded
family tree i'm ready i'm ready for a
little one so i'm looking forward to it
i don't mind if it's a boy or girl as
long as it's all there i'll be happy
lilly was born in 1989 to mother jill
tavelman and father phil collins
legendary drummer solo artist and
frontman for genesis
[Music]
lily's not the first collins to follow
her father into showbiz lily has two
half-siblings from her father's first
marriage actress jolie collins and
musician simon collins plus two more
half-brothers from her father's third
marriage nicholas and matthew lilly
recently took to instagram to praise 20
year old nicholas calling the drummer an
utter pro after he performed on stage
with their pops
and up here behind the drums
[Applause]
throughout her childhood lily tagged
along with her dad to red carpet affairs
phil even brought the family to the
academy awards in 2000 where he won best
original song for tarzan
[Music]
it's lovely to have them with me my kids
my youngest
daughter lives here she's 11. speaking
with e.t leading up to the movie's debut
the iconic musician said little lily was
excited by his latest success she calls
me out and says you know it's all over
the radio dead you know i go to school
and it's all over the billboards and
they have a big billboard on sunset well
that's all tarzan now and so she's
really thrilled about it but cut to
today and it's lily who's up on the
billboards hello
bonjour lily star is in the hit netflix
series emily in paris but her real-life
love story took place stateside after a
year of dating director charlie mcdowell
proposed in september of 2020 which she
told et was a source of joy for her
loved ones amid the coronavirus pandemic
you just got engaged so how are you
feeling about all your surprises
you got to do it you know she's part i
know it's always like it's like what
sorry what
no i'm so excited the couple later
married in september 2021 and she
provided deets to ellen about their
treehouse honeymoon it's very close
quarters and you know when you go to the
bathroom
it's um you have to
do anything you're gonna do into a paper
bag which then gets incinerated which
then turns to dust which gets buried and
made into a tree and oh yeah her new bow
has not one but two famous parents
charlie was born in 1983 his mother is
prolific movie and tv actress mary
steenburgen and his father is british
actor malcolm mcdowell i'm married an
american my wife mary steen virgin so we
have a family in the home here they had
two children son charlie and their
daughter coincidentally named lily the
actors met on the set of 1979's time
after time i always say this is one of
my favorite movies because i got two
wonderful children
as a gift from this movie mary and
malcolm divorced in 1990 but charlie's
famous family kept expanding his mother
married ted danson in 1995 following
many years of friendship what was really
great is that he was my buddy you know i
never got that before i never got that
whole thing about being friends with
somebody first i highly recommend it it
really is a rare treat at age 48
you know to get to do this ted had two
kids from a previous marriage but it
seems mary's kids fit right in with the
dancing bunch my stepson charlie you
know dragged us here it was like we
cannot miss this really and he's so hip
that i know i'm in the right place if
he's there and after 25 years of
marriage the love is still going strong
he's everything he's you know he's he's
like i would sign up for many more
lifetimes with this one i'm very blessed
pretty pretty obsessed with him actually
so today lily kimboshi has some amazing
in-laws and that rockstar dad who's
thrilled for her success i just i'd get
the impression that she could actually
put her mind to anything and do it she
has that kind of
ability
and get this her other most recent
project was a family affair
on the season finale of curb your
enthusiasm lily made a quick cameo
playing herself with her newly minted
father-in-law in the
background the last kiss because
marshall lichens is here
lily shared this behind-the-scenes pic
selfie with ted who was still wearing
makeup prosthetics in the comments
charlie joked this image will haunt me
forever
[Music]